et maintenant voici Tom villa
[Musique]
et pourquoi
il veut pas rentrer
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
le monde va bien bonsoir alors là voilà
bravo Thierry parce que là le plateau il
a de la gueule voilà Rohff Baffie on a
très jolie fille aussi Virginie Efira
Géraldine Nakache tu as eu de la chance
parce que la semaine dernière il y avait
une brune une blonde aussi mais c'était
Giesbert et bebeder ça avait pas la même
gueule quand même
alors Virginie Géraldine vous jouez deux
demi-sœurs dans le film et ta soeur de
Marion Vernoux alors c'est dommage que
ça soit pas dans un film d'Abdellatif
qui est chiche parce que vous auriez
toujours été demi-soeur mais lesbienne
et incestueuse et là c'était un César
assuré pour vous deux et ta soeur c'est
le remake français de ma meilleure amie
sa sœur et moi on aime bien faire des
remakes en France et on avait fait au
sein eleven's en français ça donnait
cash avec Jean Dujardin Fast and Furious
a donné les clés de bagnoles Laurent
Baffie
Laurent je suis très impressionné d'être
à côté de lui c'est vrai je suis un
petit peu comme le pape devant Jésus ou
Alain Delon devant Alain Delon je suis
très impressionné non mais c'est vrai
c'est le patron c'est le sniper tireur
d'élite jamais de tir de sommation
toujours entre les deux yeux c'est non
mais c'est notre meilleur soldat tu
commences une phrase il a terminé c'est
l'histoire d'une [ __ ] et d'un chameau
vas-y Laurent à toi
[Musique]
Ardisson et Baffie réunit en plus un peu
les Peter et Stone de la télé c'est vrai
besoin de rien envie d'une vanne et
alors toute la dream team et là il
manque juste Corti alors c'est pas qu'il
a pas exactement le juge d'application
des peines n'a pas voulu qu'il vienne
voilà exactement
Laurent vous venez pour un livre vous
avez fait plus de 1800 anagrammes et
d'ailleurs vous avez accusé de plagiat
par Raphaël Enthoven il vous accuse
d'avoir repris plus de 40 anagrammes
d'un autre livre pour rendre sur 1800
non mais 40 sur 1800 remarqué c'était
quand même plus rapide de compter les
anagrammes en commun que les ex de son
ex Carla Bruni donc c'est logique
[Musique]
allez à mon tour tu es en plagi pas une
anagramme quand on cherche on trouve
alors que Camus oui on plie
c'est il m'a fait aimer le rap c'est le
rappeur en activité qui a vendu le plus
d'album en France près de 20 ans de
carrière 2 millions 2 millions d'albums
pas parce que je vais t'éclater
[Applaudissements]
selon Skyrock c'est une petite
baltringue selon Booba alors juste pour
expliquer aux téléspectateurs ça fait
trois ans que vous êtes en clash avec
Booba c'est un autre rappeur par exemple
pour resituer pour mes grands-parents
qui qui regardent et qui comprennent
bien c'est un peu comme si Marcel Amont
était en guerre avec lui au frais voilà
c'est devenu un youtubeur il fait des
vidéos sur sa vie un petit peu comme
Norman tu sais Norman fait des vidéos il
fait des vidéos sur ses ex avec son chat
bon Rohff aussi avec ses expériences de
vie à lui aussi comment couper son
bracelet électronique la vie après la
tôle
ne lève pas trop quand même je sens
qu'il y a une tension pas peur
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson ici présent n'a pas
voulu vous poser Géraldine Nakache
c'était quoi le plus dur dans le film
jouant en Bretagne en plein hiver ou
faire croire que vous êtes sœur avec
Virginie
vous avez déclaré dans vos chansons ben
voilà vous parlez de la rue de la
famille des sentiments de l'amitié ça
fait quoi d'avoir les mêmes sujets que
Louane
Thierry juillet
[Musique]
notre stagiaire on retrouve ici la
semaine prochaine et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu